bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans sens public on est ensemble pour 90
minutes de débat et le reportage 90
minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts avec
deux grands thèmes ce soir dans
l'émission la visite d'Emmanuel Macron
au ProcheOrient d'abord après Benyamine
netaniaahou et Mahmoud Abbas hier le
président français a été reçu par le roi
de Jordanie et par l'égyptien Aliss il
annonce l'envoi d'un navire et de
matériel de santé pour soutenir les
hôpitaux de Gaza mais sa proposition
d'utiliser la coalition internationale
antidaesh pour s'attaquer également au
ramas continue de faire des vagues
notamment dans les pays arabes notre
second thème d'actu ce soir c'est cette
loi débattue au Sénat loi contre les
déserts médicaux ici pendant pas mal de
mois il y a plus de médecin puisque
celui du village où les trois/4s des
gens allaient est parti à à la retraite
et du coup on s'est retrouvé sans
médecin comment inciter les médecins à
s'installer dans ces territoires ruraux
faut-il aller jusqu'à la contrainte
comment redonner de l'attractivité au
métiers de santé ne ratez pas l'analyse
de nos invités dans 45 minutes mais
d'abord donc les enjeux d'une visite
risquée pour Emmanuel Macron dans une
région du monde où la voix de la France
pèse de moins en moins Samia
duchia face à l'urgence humanitaire dans
la bande de Gaza la France va déployer
une aide médicale depuis l'Égypte
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé aujourd'hui
l'envoi d'avion français chargés de
matériel médical qui se poseront demain
sur le sol égyptien une aide par les
airs mais aussi par la mer via un navire
hôpital je voulais vous annoncer ici que
j'ai pris la décision qu'un navire de
notre marine
nationale puisse appareiller
prochainement pour soutenir les hôpitaux
de Gaza il partira de Toulon dans les 48
prochaines heures les égypte marqué la
dernière étape d'une visite de 48 heures
au Proche Orient où Emmanuel Macron a
tenté de relancer le processus de paix
entre Israël et la Palestine il a
répondu aux critiques de plusieurs États
arabes qui accusent l'Occident de
pratiquer une politique du deux poids de
mesures entre victimes israéliennes et
palestiniennes je vais ici être très
clair la France ne pratique pas le
double
standard le droit international
s'applique à tout le
monde et la France a toujours porté des
valeurs universelles
d'humanisme toutes les vies se valent et
il n'y a pas de hiérarchie à l'unisson
les deux dirigeants ont prené une
solution à deux états pour Israël et la
Palestine comme la seule issue au
conflit le président égyptien a aussi
appelé à éviter une invasion terrestre
de la bande de Gaza par
Israël une invasion terrestre pourrait
avoir pour conséquence de faire à
nouveau un grand nombre de victimes
civiles on parle de déjà de près de 6000
victimes dont beaucoup sont des enfants
massés autour de la bande de Gaza
l'armée israélienne n'a pas encore reçu
l'ordre d'entrer dans l'enclave mais
elle continue les frappes aériennes qui
ont fait plus de 6500 morts à Gaza
d'après un dernier bilan 31 français ont
été tués et neuf autres pris en otage
dans les attaques du Hamas sur Israël
qui ont fait plus de 1400 morts et 200
otages le 7
octobre comment éviter un embrasement
régional du conflit c'est le thème
principal on va dire de notre débat avec
jérô cl bonsoir bienvenue vous êes
enseignant en prospective et stratégie à
science pour Paris auteur de ce livre la
prospective stratégique publié aux
éditions Herman j'accueille Anne Sophie
San bcage bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
directrice de l'American gwish Comet à
Paris et docteur en géopolitique
Emmanuel du puit bonsoir bienvenue
président de l'Institut prospective et
sécurité en Europe enseignant en
géopolitique et Mathieu croissandau
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir éditorialiste
politique allez un bilan pour commencer
tout simplement Jérôme clche quel bilan
vous faites de ces de jours de visite de
du président français au au proch rant
c'est une sacrée question pour commencer
quand même oui c'est vaste parce qu'en
fait quels étaient les objectifs ils ont
été indiqués par Emmanuel Macron
lui-même qui a dit je me rendrai en
Israël si ça peut être utile et donc la
question était d'être utile utile à quoi
les objectifs c'est évidemment le
premier et pour tous si je puis dire la
libération des otages évidemment c'est
et c'est le thème de autre émission
éviter l'embrasement et les escalade et
on y reviendra et puis c'est aussi dans
le sillage de ces massacres 15 jours
après la possibilité d'ouvrir sans doute
euh une
réflexion une approche plus nuancée qui
n'était pas permise au lendemain des
massacres où seule la voix de
l'indignation pouvait être audible et
donc c'est sans doute aussi ce tonlà
qu'il a pu apporter notamment avec le
double standard sur lequel il répondait
qui n'était pas possible pour ichiunak
ou qui n'était pas pas possible pour son
homologue allemand et qui fin pouvit
apparaître comme une erreur d'arriver
trop tard ça il a pu le transformer
en jamais une erreur le temps de la
réflexion est jamais une erreur parce
que ça a permis d'aussi véhiculer des
messages qui sont importants et pour
l'après et aussi pour le règlement de la
crise c'est-à-dire pour les otages et
pour éviter l'embrasement parce qu'à
l'heure où les pays arabes ne font pas
tous la distinction entre le Hamas et la
cause palestinienne il importe
aujourd'hui d'être toujours en capacité
de s'indigner de ces massacres que le
Hamas a causé et en même temps de
comprendre qu'il y a une cause
palestinienne qui pour le bien-être même
d'Israël et son existence doit aussi
être porté y compris dans le temps de la
crise Anne Sophie c'est bon Bach est-ce
que effectivement il y a pas eu de
double langage de la part d'Emmanuel
Macron avec les deux temps de de sa
visite est-ce que vous approuvez
finalement ce ce on l'a vu dans le sujet
quand il dit la France ne pratique pas
le double standard j' j'apouve et je je
souscris à ce qui vient d'être h h eff
arrivant 17 jours après visite é
forcément plus ambieuse parce qu'il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses entreemps
et parce que les objectifs sont
forcément plus nombreux mais je crois
pas qu'il a tenu double langage j'ai
vraiment écouté chaque allocution qu'il
a fait avec le Premier ministre
netaniahù puis avec Mahmoud Abbas
aujourd'hui j'ai écoutter juste avant
notre émission La loocution avec le
président égyptien il a tenu le même
langage c'est-à-dire en disant que que
les objectifs sont repose sur différents
pliers il y a d'abord la lutte sans
merci et sans ambigué contre le
terrorisme et et lutte à laquelle
doivent participer les alliés de la
France mais aussi les États régionaux
puisque le ramas est l'ennemi d'Israël
mais aussi des Palestiniens mais aussi
des Égyptiens et et et alors tous les
dirigeants arabes disent pas ça
aujourd'hui mais on y reviendra un peu
plus tard il a tenu ce message clair à
tous les interlocuteurs autre autre
élément évidemment la libération des des
otages troisième pilier évidemment
l'accès humanitaire le respect du droit
humanitaire international et tout faire
pour qu'il y ait de moins le moins
possible de victimes civil à Gaza
d'ailleurs le je vous interromp avant le
4e élément le navire hôpital français
c'est le tonner qui a apparillé depuis
Toulon pour pour Gaza c'est une des
informations de cette fin d'après-midi
4è point par tout à fait et le dernier
point c'est euh envisager en tout cas
poser les jalons de la perspective
politique qui devra être être mis sur la
table pour la résolution du conflit
entre israélien et Palestiniens donc
c'est très ambitieux ouais Emmanuel
est-ce que c'était à la hauteur de ces
ambitions est-ce qu'il y a une voix
diplomatique française qui s'exprime là
ou est-ce que finalement on est un peu à
la remorque de du géant américain que
c'est une position assez classique de la
le prtique qui a été évoqué par le
président Macron à l'occasion de la
conférence de presse ont été finalement
abondé la lutte contre le terrorisme
avec cette idée un peu ce grenu je pense
qu'on y reviendraid d'uneition
parallélisme d'une coalition antidaehh
la coalition globale contre contre DAEs
il réuni 86 pays l'aide humanitaire et
ça il faut se il faut s'en réjouir avec
un certain nombre de décisions qui ont
été prises en plus de ce que vous avez
annoncé 20 millions d'euros
supplémentaire pour l'aide humanitaire
d'urgence plus donc le porte le porte
hélicoptère hibie qui rappelle que le
l'épisode en 2014 au cours duquel
l'Égypte en avait bénéficié de de
nouveau et puis bien évidemment la la
solution politique maintenant la
solution politique il y a pas eu
beaucoup d'avancé en tout cas il y a une
différenceatus trop pouril a des
avancées c'est trop tard dirons certains
parce que ça fait quand même depuis près
de TR euh disons 78 ans que l'on pense à
la question la résolu première
résolution de résolution 181 qui précise
le de états c'est 1947 et la résolution
auquelle fait référence le président
Macron qui l'a rappelé à ses
interlocuteurs la réstion 242 c'est 1967
donc ça fait quand même très longtemps
qu'on aurait dû aboutir pour éviter les
ferement de la colère je prends ce qu'a
dit le roi Abdallah et ce qu'a rappelé
le président Sissi moi je vois peut-être
un autre élément de de réponse à votre
question s'il n'y avait eu cette
proposition un peu secenu de la
coalition le voyage de con était
peut-être plus pertinent que le voyage
de Joe Biden le voyage de Joe Biden est
arrivé au moment où il n'a pas pu voir
tous ses intercucteur puisqu'il n'a pas
été reçu il y a eu l'exlosion de de
l'hôpital de Gaza c'est la raison
principale l'annulation duipartide c'est
ça absolument mais disons que le
président Biden avait aussi un autre
agenda en tête qui était un agenda
politique à Washington et de ce point de
vue forcé de constater que ce n'a pas
beaucoup avancé l'idée du président
Macron je crois était la bonne de voir à
la fois les autorit israélienne
palestinienne devir autorités
égyptiennes je rappelle que le blocus
n'est pas seulement israélien c'est un
blocus égypto-israélien et de ce point
de vue il fallait rencontrer les
présences ici même si effectivement la
la visite de Joe Biden dans dans la
foulée de ce de de sa visite il y a deux
éages Américaines qui ont été libéré on
peut peut-être mettre ça à son crédit
mais je voudrais qu'on passe du temps
sur effectivement le mot coalition
Mathieu il a été prononcé peut-être un
peu à la surprise générale par le
président français hier oui lors de sa
conférence de presse hier au côté du
Premier ministre ministre benjamine
netaniahou donc Emmanuel Macron a
formulé un souhait ou plutôt une
possibilité la France est prête a-t-il
dit à ce que la coalition internationale
contre daesh dans le cadre de laquelle
nous sommes pour notre opération en Irak
et en Syrie puisse lutter contre le
Hamas et d'insister en ajoutant par la
suite qu'il proposait à tous ses
partenaires de bâtir une coalition
régionale et internationale pour lutter
contre les groupes terroristes qui nous
menacent tous alors cette proposition
c'est vrai qu'elle a surpris beaucoup de
monde elle avait été évoquée dit-on à
l'Élysée par le Président de la
République notamment lors de l'échange
téléphonique qui a pu avoir dimanche so
avec Joe Biden Richy sunac Georgia
Meloni Olaf CHS était une une
conversation à 5 mais elle a surpris
jusqu'à benamin netaniaou d'une certaine
façon qui n'a pas répondu à cette offre
de service de façon précise elle a
surpris aussi et choqué dans certaines
capitales arabes pour qui daesh n'égale
pas le Hamas ou plutôt le Hamas n'est
pas daesh et puis chez de nombreux
experts qui la juge tout simplement en
l'état infaisable au point que l'éisée a
dû faire une forme de rétropédalage
alors on va le détailler pourquoi
infaisable mais on voit bien l'objectif
d'abord internationaliser la lutte
contre le terrorisme un mal qui frappe y
compris la France sur son propre sol et
en learant en le comparant pardon le
Hamas avec daesh en gros disqualifier le
Hamas comme représentant comme
interlocuteur pour la suite mais ça pose
quand même deux questions simples he
d'abord coalition avec qui à l'inverse
de ce qui s'était passé avec l'État
islamique qui était une menace pour
beaucoup beaucoup d'États dans la région
ben c'est pas le cas du Hamas c'est de
nombreux pays du Proche Orient refuse
précisément cette disqualification du
Hamas comme futur interlocuteur et puis
don certains il faut le rappeler aussi
héberge hein certains représentants du
Hamas je pense au Qatar il y en a aussi
en Turquie ensuite une coalition pour
faire quoi en pratique des frappes des
interventions militaires sur le terrain
comme en Syrie ou en Irak Israël n'est
pas demandeur ni les pays qui
soutiennent la cause palestinienne
évidemment et puis je pas certain qu'en
France tout le monde soit demandeur pour
qu'il y ait une intervention sur le
terrain l'Élysée alors du coup a précisé
par la suite que la coalition contre
l'État islamique c'était qu'une
référence qu'une nouvelle coalition ne
voulait pas forcément dire
une coalition militaire mais surtout
politique avec échange de renseignement
sanction lutte contre le financement
avec au fond un Paris risqué peut-être
l'espoir d'avoir droit au chapitre enfin
d'avoir voix pardon au chapitre pour
encadrer laariposte israélienne s'il y
avait une coalition vous savez le
président a dit hier lut sans merci oui
mais pas lut sans règle il a rappelé à
Benyamine netaniaahou mais c'est pas
sans risque cette affaire parce que ça
vous met aussi dans la roue de du
gouvernement israélien et ça vous fait
apparaître comme solidaire de toutes les
fr
actuelle ou à venir pour conclure est-ce
que ça a une chance de voir le jour
cette on verra ce que vous en dites mais
aujourd'hui non du tout il y a un
sentiment de PR d'impréparation voire de
de précipitation ou d'improvisation qui
domine même si cette décision avait
quand même discuter précis c'est pas
avec le CORC paraît-il c'est en tout cas
ce que dit le monde aujourd'hui même les
États-Unis ont poliment beauté en touche
donc je pense pas que ça puisse voir le
jour dès demain on en parle tout de
suite avec nos invités évidemment Anne
Sophie S ia y a il y a d'abord
effectivement cette question du Hamas
est-ce que les les massacres du 7
octobre placent cette organisation
définitivement dans la case terroriste
et et la rendre comparable à daesh
évidemment ENF c'est une preuve de plus
sil en fallait puisque le ramas n'en est
pas à sa première activité terroriste
dès les années 80 le ramas perpétrait
des attentats terroristes en Israël dès
qu'il y a eu des accords de paix
d'ailleurs dans les périodes dans la
période des accords d'Oslo dans la
période de cand David c'est là que le
Hamas a perpétré ses attaques
terroristes les plus plus meurtrière et
on le voit ici à un moment aussi
d'apaisement où Israël et l'Arabie
Saoudite étaient sur le point de signer
un accord donc là-dessus je crois qu'il
y a pas de cette attaque ne confirme
confirme s'il en fallait mais la
communauté internationale considérait
cette organisation comme une
organisation terroriste à juste titre et
n'est pas l'interlocuteur des israéliens
dans le cadre du processus de paix
puisque c'est l'autorité palestinienne
qui l' donc là-dessus je pense que cet
acteur était déjà disqualifié c'est vrai
que certains pays arabes ne le voient
pas de cette il mais je crois je crois
que c'était aussi l'objectif du
président Macron de clarifier ça auprès
des des pays voisins de leur faire dire
on a même vu dans l'échange avec
marmouabas qui n'a pas condamné
l'attaque du 7 octobre et le président
lui dire je comprends pas on s'est parlé
en coulisse vous avez vous-même en off
condamn condamner cette attaque et dit
et même affirmeré que c'était une tâche
sur la cause palestinienne donc ça c'est
c'est le premier point et la réalité
c'est que le ramas ne menace pas
qu'Israël il a déjà aussi bon déjà dans
cette attaque du 7 octobre on le sait il
y a 31 victimes françaises il y a
d'autres nationalités qui ont été
touchées également parmi les otages et
par le passé typiquement quand on prend
le cas de l'Égypte l'Égypte qui est donc
le l'autre pays qui a une frontière avec
la bande de Gaza il y a quelques années
il y a 5 ans le ramas avait laissé des
combattants de daesh sortir de la bande
de Gaza qui sont été pris à des
policiers et des gardes frontière
égyptiens qu's avaient massacré alors
qu'ils étaient en pleine prière du
Ramadan donc il faut bien voir que c'est
aussi une menace et un ennemi très
identifi par les Égyptiens alors moi je
pense que effectivement les les les
massacres du 7 octobre ont d'une
certaine façon placent leur mass dans
une autre catégorie qui était pas la
sienne auparavant et et qui moi c'est ma
perception hein la classe définitivement
comme une organisation terroriste mais
c'est pas du tout la perception de
beaucoup de pays arabes le président
turc par exemple Recep TP Erdogan alors
c'est c'est une déclaration
d'aujourd'hui et regrette d'avoir serré
la main de Benyamine netaniiaou c'était
au mois de septembre on était dans une
dans un processus voilà de de
rapprochement on va dire comme ça il dit
je cite le président turc le Hamas n'est
pas un groupe terroriste mais un groupe
de libérateur luttant pour protéger sa
terre Emmanuel duplu est-ce qu'on peut
mettre daesh et le ramas dans la même
catégorie aujourd'hui d'près non même si
elles sont considérées comme
organisation terroriste selon les mêmes
conditions d'emploi de la terreur mais
je crois qu'il y a quand même une que
les actes ne suffisent pas à les classer
dans la même catégorie alors déjà il y a
des il y a certains pays qui font la
différence entre la branche politique et
la branche militaire les brigades Cassam
qui pour certains ne sont pas enfin qui
sont considérés comme terroristes alors
que la brche politique ne l' pas c'est
par exemple le cas de la Grande-Bretagne
moi je crois qu'il y a quand même
effectivement une difficulté
insummontable pour cette coalition si on
prend celle contre daesh c'est qu'il a
fallu 10 ans pour la monter déjà c'est
pas fait
avec avec facilité qu'un certain nombre
de pays jouent là pour le coup les
doubles SARD puisqu'ils accueillent
aussi sur leur sol un certain nombre de
militants qui sont supposés combattre
c'est le cas du Qatar je ne vois pas en
quoi et comment il pourrait faire partie
de cette coalition ou le président
Erdogan pour la Turquie je crois aussi
qu'il y a une différence d'approche avec
un certain nombre de pays qui font bien
la différence entre la manière dont la
population Gazaoui
reconnaît le droit à son existence et la
manière dont le Hamas et le dihad
islamique sont en train de prendre en
otage doublement la population
palestinienne comme la population
israélienne je ne crois pas non plus que
le Premier ministre Benjamin netaniahou
a été très Friant de cette idée
qui consisterait à donner l'impression
qu' n'a plus la main dans la manière
dont il veut répondre lui-même à cette
attaque qui tch improvisation
présidentielle C annonce c'est sophisme
c'est un sophisme d'ailleurs si on
écoute bien la conférence de presse tout
à l'heure il a parlé de comparaison il a
parlé de tirer les conséquences de la
coalition il a évoqué le fait qu'il
s'agirait pas d'une réponse militaire
c'est un peu le rétropédalage on parler
matie alors on peut appeler ça ropage
mais c'est plus précisément une
évocation de deux choses qui n'ont pas
grand chose à voir ement il y a une
opération militaire dans lequel nous
sommes engagés dans le cadre de
l'opération Chamal qui cynétiquement
combat les militants de daesh en Syrie
en Irak ce n'est pas le la même mission
de la coalition globale contre daesh et
donc il je pense qu'il a tenu à mettre
cette précision alors plusieurs
personnes qui veulent prendre la parole
je vous la redonner Mathieu unot juste
une question parce que qu'on qu'on les
qu'on mette en en équivalence le fait
que ce soit deux organisation terroriste
moi ça ne me pose pas de souci c'est ce
qu'on a vu qu'on disent qu'il y a eu une
forme de de de de barbarie absolue de la
part du Hamas qui fait penser à la
barbarie absolue de daesh oui mais
est-ce que l'agenda politique peut être
mis en équivalence moi il me semblait
quand j'ai Luu la charte du Hamas il y a
pas une volonté expansionniste ou de
fracturer les sociétés idental comme
c'est était écrit noir sur blanc dans
les écrits de DA alors peut-être un mot
vous voulez prendre la parole et juste
après g bah peut-être pour vous répondre
et puis je il y a deux types
d'organisation djihadistes il y a celles
qui ont un ennemi local comme enfin un
objet local comme le Hamas comme DAEs
d'ailleurs don objectif c'est de créer
un khalifat de créer un État islamique
et il y a al-qïda qui avait qui a une
cible plus lointaine c'està dire
directement et de de cibler les
démocraties mais quand on lit la charte
du ramas c'est l'établissement d'un État
islamique sur toute la terre de paessie
donc c'est l'éradication de l'État
d'Israël dans état Yuden Rin si on peut
dire comme ça et et et par la suite
aussi éliminer t tous les mécréants et
on le voit le ramas ne fait pas la
différence entre les cibles juiv non
juives voir même des musulmans qui ont
été tués aussi en Israël ensuite sur
juste un mot sur la coalition parce que
j'ai vu aussi l'évolution de la parole
du président dans ses différentes
déclarations et effectivement là avec le
président égyptien il parle plus de
tirer les leçons de la coalition
internationale de lutte contre daesh
pour créer une autre coalition de lutte
contre le terrorisme qui viendrait
notamment permettre une coopération plus
édroite en matière de renseignement en
matière de lutte contre les flux
financiers et où évidemment tous les
acteurs ne pourront pas en faire Repti
puis qu'on sait typiquement que le un
état comme le Qatar non seulement abrite
les dirigeants du Hamas mais aussi et le
principal pourvoyeur financier de cette
organisation mais mais le symbole était
important c'est là aussi que la visite
apporté un message de clarté sur la
détermination des démocraties des alliés
y compris des pays régionaux à lutter
contre ces groupes terroristes jérme cl
est-ce qu'il faut pas mettre cette cette
déclaration je reviens à la déclaration
initiale he du du président français
avec la la question de l'offensive de la
reposte non
unitit il il y a que ce sujetl le reste
j'allais dire c'est de la littérature
des exégèes sur lesquels on peut gloser
sans fin le seul sujet c'était de
conjurer d'une certaine manière la
possibilité l'option funeste de
l'offensive terrestre le président Biden
a réussi donne quoi une alternative
Emmanuel Macron en parlant de cette
c'est une façon finalement de de
divertir de d'amener le sujet de la Rost
et du traitement de la neutralisation du
Hamas qui est le troisième objectif
derrière derrière la libération des
otage de le de le traiter d'une autre
façon de le diluer finalement en le
dépossédant c'est vrai aussi d'une
certaine manière mais il ne l'a pas il
ne l'a pas agréé en le dépossédant d'une
partie de la réponse au nom du fait que
et bien il y a eu de faites une
internationalisation du conflit à
travers la la nationalité des otages et
que la mission première reste de libérer
les otages c'est une façon de conjurer
effectivement cette offensive terrestre
dont on sait que non seulement elle a
toutes les chances de mettre en danger
la vie des otages mais qu'elle
constituerait le fameux casus Belly qui
nous amènerait à l'embrasement à
l'escalade que tout le monde veut éviter
le président Biden a réussi à repousser
cette offensive terrestre il s'en est
défendu en remontant dans l'avion en
disant qu'il avait répondu à une autre
question qui est est celle de la
libération des notages et non pas est-ce
que vous avez essayé de faire reporter
cette offensive terrestre et puis
maintenant c'est un secret de polyinel
on saord il est à l'origine de ça
aujourd'hui le président français d'une
certaine manière repousse aussi à sa
mesure cette offensive terrestre qui
probablement n'aura jamais lieu en tout
cas dans la forme qui était attendue
initialement alors on va en parler
justement de cette offensive Thérèse je
vous propose d'entendre pour ouvrir ce
ce ce chapitre le Premier ministre
israélien Benjamin netaniaou il est face
à des soldats du génie militaire
écoutez nous sommes à la veille de la
prochaine étape elle est en route vous
le savez vous en faites parti vous êtes
le fer de lance j'apprécie vraiment
votre savoir-faire votre combativité
votre volonté de sauver notre pays de
ces
[Musique]
animaux déclaration fait il y a quelques
heures c'est ça date de ce mercredi
Emmanuel dupuie cette offensive Thérèse
qui sera pas seulement Thérèse
d'ailleurs c cette repost
israélienne là quand on entend benamin
netanahou elle semble inéuctable oui
alors je je crois que pour revenir à la
conversation qu'on a eu ensemble sur ce
plateau je crois que le président Macron
ne rend pas service au président Biden
parce que Biden a bien évidemment essayé
aussi de repousser l'attaque mais pas de
l'annuler c'est une nuance importante je
crois que le président Biden et le
Premier ministre Netanyahou repousseent
l'offensive pour pouvoir se préparer
militairement je ne dis pas de l'annuler
de la dénaturer de la d'accord
alors fort de C de cette comparaison je
crois que le président manuel Macron
entend lui avec ses interlocuteurs qui
l' rencontré mammoud Abbas le roi
Abdallah et le et le président Sissi
inscrire le processus dans un temps
beaucoup plus long d'ailleurs ça a été
rappelé par le président Sissi la
réponse politique le dialogue politique
la perspective de la solution à deux
états doit nous ramener à la table des
négociations donc je pense qu'il y a
deux approches différentes les
Américains sont prêts à ce que les
Israéliens temporis pour l'instant leur
opération militaire parce que les
Américains sont en train d'amener des
moyens militaires dans la zone de por
avion 5000 hommes avec une capacité et
d'éviter ou de répondre à un
embrassement régional le président
Emmanuel Macron l'a évoqué mais très
timidement
enfin pardon qu vous dit dénaturer
l'opération dé fait initialement
l'opération avec toutes les les forces
que vous avez de masser autour de la la
bande de Gaza les chars l'artillerie les
blindés de transport de troupe c'était
pour une invasion massive j'allais dire
une invasion terrestre bon teint de
sorte à ensuite occuper voir si ça doit
durer plus longtemps annexé c'était ça
quand même l'idée a été écartée par le
ministre de la Défense israélien
lui-même mais en l'écartant c'est une
façon de rappeler aussi que c'est quand
même ça l'enjeu et il serait plus
probable qu'il n'y ait finalement qu'une
succession dans la durée de H and run
comme on dit c'est-à-dire d'action
commando ciblé visant à je ne sais pas
trop quoi finalement parce que reprendre
les otages c'est hors de portée pour ces
actions là sauf à avoir du renseignement
et de savoir qu'il y a des clusters
d'otage hit mais sin c'est deé et si
c'est neutralis le Hamas ou aller plus
loin que ce qu'on fait les frappes
aériennes en réalité c'est un travail
sans fin parce que vous compariez on
comparait le Hamas avec l'État islamique
le Hamas c'est d'abord un bureau
politique un bras armé qui effectivement
s'identifie à l'état islamique par
l'ampleur et l'ignominie des massacres
mais qui n'a absolument rien à voir dans
sa genèse et dans sa constitution et
donc ça ça change tout ça change à sa
catégorie et ça change à la façon don on
peut traiter donc cette offensive
terrestre finalement par ses actions
commando dilué dans la durée ne peut pas
atteindre son objectif voilà mais
comment on pourrait la dénaturer parce
que une action comme celle-ci serait
sous le spectre et sous le seuil d'un
déclenchement et d'un
embrasementop B il y a un autre aspect
côté israélien c'est quand même des
lignes de de fracture entre certains
généraux et Benyamin netaniaahou il y a
il y a des reproches de tergiversation
exprimé par certains Gén ministres
anonymement dans la presse israélienne
contre le Premier ministre oui bien sûr
c'est sûr que sa côe de popularité là
est très très extrêmement basse et
d'ailleurs on a vu dans les premiers
jours après 7 octobre il s'est un peu il
s'est fait petit benami netaniaou et on
entendait plus que le chef d'état-major
le ministre de la Défense qui ont énoncé
les objectifs de cette
opération et ils sont très clairs c'est
détruire éradiquer les infrastructures
du ramas et je crois que rien ne fera
reculer ne pourra empêcher cette
opération là c'est impossible aucun
autre état ne renoncerait à une haripost
lourde après l'attaque du 7 octobre
c'est 1400 victimes c'est c'est un
cataclysme sécuritaire psychologique
pour la société israélienne c'est la
nécessité pour un état de restaurer la
frontière à ses à sa la sécurité à ses
frontières pardon de rétablir son sa
capacité de dissuasion et c'est
impossible autrement et je pense malgré
le nombre de victimes civiles je suis
pas en train de de mettre en parallèle
les uns et les autres mais il y a déjà
beaucoup victimes civiles même si les
chiffres donnés par le RAM sont sans
doute à à prendre avec des pincettes
mais il y a déjà beaucoup de victimes
civiles notamment des enfants dans la
dans la bande de Gaza s'il y a une
opération terrestre il y en aura encore
combien de milliers supplémentaires mais
c'est aussi pour ça que je pense que la
notion de coalition internationale est
intéressante et le fait que l'opération
a été décalé c'est aussi pour ça c'est
évidemment la négociation du corridor
humanitaire qui est indispensable c'est
de laisser la possibilité de négocier la
libération d'otage évidemment mais cette
ripos militaire elle est elle est
incontournable
ut dansanalse je pense qu'il faut aussi
sépareros qui est légitime et qui est
soutenu par la communauté internationale
Macron n'a pas dit qu'il ne soutenait
pas le droit légitime défense d'Israël
et qu'il ne soutenait pas cette
opération il faut distinguer cette Rost
de l'escalade puisque l'escalade elle
concerne qui elle concerne Hezbollah
elle concerne l'Iran et donc pour la il
a s'agit pour les États-Unis pour pour
la France de faire pression sur ces
états de faire pression sur ses acteurs
pour il n'ouvre pas un second front h
c'est très important ce que vous dites
parce que évidemment dans l'argumentaire
d'un certain nombre de de de de chefs
d'État ou de membres de gouvernement de
de pays arabes il y a justement
attention l'offensive la riposte
israélienne pourrait déclencher
l'embrasement écoutons ensemble le
ministre turc des Affaires étrangères
exactement sur ce
thème notre région est littéralement à
un tournant soit nous parvenons à une
solution pacifique soit il y aura une
guerre qui aura des répercussions sur le
monde entier
bar tous mes interlocuteurs partagent ce
point de vue même s'ils ne le disent pas
publiquement Emmanuel dupu est-ce que
les alliés d'Israël tiennent aussi ce
discours c'est qu'il y a le discours
officiel effectivement Israël a le droit
à se défendre après cette attaque
terroriste et massacre
voilà dont on a enfin moi j'ai pas vu
les images mais il a des journalistes
étrangers à qui l'armée israélienne a
proposé c'était lundi de de de voir ces
images avec un un choc qui a été massif
encore une fois bref est-ce que les
alliés occidentaux d'Israël tiennent
quand même le discours retenez votre
glève attention à la riposte attention à
l'embrasement bah je crois que ça a été
résumé par la prise de parole de notre
minist d'affaires étrangères Cathrine
Colona à l'ONU l'article 51 de la Charte
des Nations Unies qui précise qu'un État
a le droit de se défendre quand il y a
une attaque contre son intégrité
territoriale c'est le cas les opérations
avaient lieu en Israël et puis une
volonté je crois de la communauté
internationale dans son exception
occidentale d'essayer de toujours faire
la distinction entre la réponse et la
riposse militaire qui est parfaitement
légitime au regard de la sidération de
ces attaques du 7 octobre et puis
surtout ne jamais oublier le maintien
même si c'est une ligne de crête tenue h
d'une solution à deux états même si
c'est un mantrra que on réexume
maintenant en tout cas d'une solution
politique et je crois que ça a été rappé
par l'ensemble des interlocuteurs oua
mais à quel moment on la ripose Israël
euh risque de sortir justement de de son
droit à la légitime défense et la la
question alors allez-y ben gérche
allez-y non mais top maintenant parce
qu'en fait c'est c'est ça le problème
c'est qu'en fait la légitime défense et
c'est vrai au plan individuel et c'est
vrai au plan collectif il y a un
caractère quand même instantané
c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du moment où la
menace a fini de s'exprimer de s'exercer
de se
matérialiser vous n'êtes plus tellement
dans la défense mais vous êtes dans la
riposte les représailles et ça c'est
interdit et c'est là où la ligne de
crête qui était tenue et tenue dans les
premiers jours dans les premières
semaines commence aujourd'hui à être
difficile à tenir et c'est pour ça aussi
que les discours plus nuancés commence à
devenir audible et c'est pour ça aussi
que aller plus loin dans une opération
terrestre qui pourrait
déclencher de plusieurs fronts alors je
suis d'accord avec vous il y aura pas
plusieurs fronts symétriques avec l'Iran
contre Israël puisque ça c'est dissuadé
par la force de frappe américaine à la
faveur des deux pores-avion
essentiellement en tout cas c'est le
Paris qui est fait et ça devrait tenir
mais qui a des fronts asymétriques qui
se développent avec le hzbollah et
éventuellement aussi sur la le côté
syrien ça c'est quelque chose qui est
possible et qu'il faut tenir donc donc
ce que j'entends et je vous pose la
question si
Israël enclenche sa sa ripost militaire
dans Gaza il y aura à minima une
réplique du Hezbollah par exemple ça
semble ça dépendra de l'ampleur je crois
que mon collègue l'a dit si c'est une
opération domin c'est une opération de
style fin du blocus et réengagement des
des forces armées israéliennes comme
avant 2005 au moment où elles étaient
encore dans Gaza là ça devrait
déclencher une réponse symétrique
parallèle en tout cas c'est le discours
qui a été prononcé et tenu par le guide
suprême iranien ou par Hassan nasrala le
secrétaire général du hbola maintenant
il y a aussi un autre un autre élément
vous dites c'est rhtorique moi je pense
que c'est de la rhétorique et qu'en
réalité quand on regarde les intérêts de
chacun enfin ni le hzbollah aujourd'hui
ni le Liban ni l'Iran n'ont intérêt à
déclencher une guerre totale avec Israël
non mais je pense qu'on est d'accord
mais du coup on peut pas voir
l'enchaînement des faits comme étant de
cause à effet
puisque est dans la rtorique
d'organisation terroriste et
d'État je RP je réponds également sur un
un point qui est très important dans
notre dans l'arithmétique c'est la
dimension politique israélienne
il y a évidemment euh un premier
ministre fort euh délégitimé par cette
opération un article du Washington Post
nous indique qu'il y a un certain nombre
de failles sécuritaires qui ont été
révélées la surprise a été aussi pour
les les services de renseignement
américain de constater que les services
de renseignement israélien étaient pas
tout à fait informés en tout cas ils
avaient pris la position de s'informer
sur la branche politique et pas du tout
sur la branche militaire mais il y a
aussi une crise politique en Israël deux
réformes très très très disputées
disons-le avec beaucoup de diplomatie la
réforme judiciaire et la réforme
institutionnelle ont sensiblement
affaibli politiquement le Premier
ministre les critiques sont à
l'intérieur de son gouvernement elles
sont également dans son cabinet de
guerre vous mentionnez les généraux
l'ancien ministre de la Défense
benigantz a dit qu'il soutenait par
obligation de réplique immédiate euh la
position du Premier ministre mais
qu'ensuite viendra le temps de des du de
le du réflexe politique il là pour le
coup devrait sans doute voir le Premier
ministre choisir entre les radicau qui
auraiit dont certains disent qu'ils sont
à l'origine de la crise et les autres
qui voudraient se débarrasser du premier
ministreion é pour le coup Emmanuel
Macron a vu tout le monde c'est aussi
une des spécificités de cette visite de
du chef de l'État puisqu'il a vu
notamment l'opposant de de de benjamine
netanahou monsieur lapide et puis il a
vu bigance aussi
euhou et et il a vu une façon de montrer
qu'il soutenait Israël et pas
forcément effectivement le message
politique est passé et le président
français a également rencontré le roi de
Jordanie on en parle tout de suite avec
Mathias
Arz bienvenue Mathias sur ce plateau que
peut-on dire sur la Jordanie pour nous
éclairer ce et bien dans ce que certains
présentent comme la poudrière du
Moyen-Orient la Jordanie représente un
pôle de stabilité c'est une monarchie
constitutionnelle d'un peu plus de 11
millions d'habit an qui ne compte ni
pétrole ni gaz pour autant la Jordanie
est un acteur majeur de la région qui a
à plusieurs reprises fait la guerre à
Israël depuis
1948 en 1994 les deux pays signent des
accords bilatéraux de paix qui ont
normalisé les relations et qui ont même
permis de la coopération dans certains
domaines notamment économique depuis les
années 2000 et l'arrivée au pouvoir
d'Abdallah i le roi Abdallah 2 le
gouvernement jordanien s'est souvent
montré soucieux de maintenir une paix
durable avec tous ses voisins com
comment a réagi la Jordanie depuis les
les attaques du 7 octobre alors sans
toutefois condamner les attaques du
Hamas le roi Abdallah I a joué la carte
diplomatique dans les tous premiers
jours le souverain jordanien a décroché
son téléphone Joe Biden l'égyptien al
sic le président du Conseil européen
Charles Michel Mahmoud Abbas déjà
Emmanuel Macron à l'époque avec un
objectif qui a un peu glissé d'abord
appelé au calme et puis peu à peu
ramener le projecteur sur Gaza
d'ailleurs hier soir la reine Rania de
Jordanie est sortie du silence c'était
lors d'une interview pour la chaîne
américaine
CNN nous sommes choqués et déçu par la
réaction du monde face à cette
catastrophe qui se déroule ces deux
dernières semaines nous observons
clairement deux poids de mesures quand
les attaques du 7 octobre ont eu lieu le
monde a immédiatement soutenu sans
équivoque Israël dans son droit à se
défendre et condamner les attaques mais
ces deux dernières semaines il n'y a que
du
silence voilà la visite d'Emmanuel
Macron en Jordanie en Égypte peut avoir
un lien justement avec ces ces ce type
de réaction dans les pays arabes en tout
cas ce n'est pas impossible on le sait
he la colère gronde dans le monde arabe
notamment vis-à-vis des alliés d'Israël
la semaine dernière en Tunisie en
Algérie et dans d'autres pays musulmans
des manifestations ont eu lieu contre
les pays jugés sionistes et notamment
des attaques à destination de la France
n'ont pas manqué c'est donc tout
naturellement qu'Emmanuel Macron était
attendu au tournant pour donner des
gages de soutien au palestiniens au
pays- voisins arabes ou alors peut-être
qu'il cherchait des soutiens pour sa
fameuse coalition contre le Hamas merci
beaucoup Mathias Jérôme clè si on
cherche un peu on va ouvrir ce chapitre
maintenant des modérateurs ou des
négociateurs le roi Abdallah i de
Jordanie fait-il partie de ces
négociateurs potentiel est-ce qu'il
parleent aux deux camps oui il parle au
deux camps après reste le Qatar et la
Turquie sans doute aux avant-plan et
comme on le disait aussi et sur votre
plateau il y a il y a peut-être 15 jours
euh le centre de gravité de cette
affaire c'est pas tant le Hamas encore
une fois que l'Iran et pour l'instant la
capacité à activer l'Iran et reste
faible or pour une libération en masse
des otages parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'on est plus dans une approche
incrémentale avec le Qatar la Turquie ça
aura été bien mais là manifestement
elle a elle a elle a viré viré de bord
d'un coup c'est une approche
incrémentale mais pour une libération en
masse c'est plutôt en Iran que ce sit
les clés or là nous n'avons pas nous
occidentaux véritablement l'entregens
qu'il faut il faudrait pouvoir toucher
la Chine il faudrait pouvoir toucher la
Russie la Turquie peut toucher la Russie
qui elle peut toucher Israël et l'Iran
voilà c'est là que se situe
véritablement le centre de gravité de
négociation pour une libération en masse
faute de ça et en l'occurrence nous non
ça nous fait défaut faute de ça
effectivement l'approche incrémentale
est à privilégieré et dans ce cas-là
c'est plutôt le Qatar
plutôt la Turquie qui reviendra
peut-être parce que la Turquie est très
volatile aussi et dans ses revirements
demain elle peut dire le contraire de ce
qu'elle a dit aujourd'hui et se poser en
intermédiaire je rappelle quand même
qu'elle a elle a donné son accord pour
l'accession de la Suède à l'OTAN c'était
vra c'était avanthier donc c'était
vraisemblablement pour se rapprocher et
se poser en médiateur en assouplissant
les relations avec les États-Unis donc
tout ça peut revenir la Jordanie oui
sans doute aussi mais ça me semble pas
être le le proxy numéro 1
l'interlocuteur en tout celui qui sera
en tête de de négociation je je reviens
un tout petit peu en arrière dans notre
dans la thématique de notre débat avec
cette déclaration du président français
sur l'opération terrestre la forme de
l'opération de la riposte israélienne
une opération terrestre massive d'Israël
serait une erreur voilà les mots
d'Emmanuel Macron évidemment ça éclaire
ce que l'on disait auparavant et
justement cette pression Emmanuel duuis
que les alliés d'Israël sont en train de
mettre sur l'État hébreux on peut en
revenir à la dernière opération donc en
de 2014 ou en 2021 au cours duquel par
exemple prenon celle de 2014 qui av duré
50 jours il y a eu des opérations donc
précises pour viser le leadership
politique du Hamas d'ailleurs yov galent
auquel vous faites référence m la
défense a dit qu'il allait éradiquer le
Hamas à les infrastructure ça ce sont
les opérations qui ont déjà été menées
les frappes si on va chercher sur le
terrain les leaders du hamaas c'est pour
les mettre hors d'état de nuire ou pour
les neutraliser dit très poliment donc
je crois qu'effectivement il y a là
aussi
de part et d'autre dans le camp
israélien ceux qui veulent aller
beaucoup plus loin Itamar benir le
ministre de la Sécurité nationale lui
voudrait sans doute accélérer le
processus de de repost militaire
d'ailleurs il a il est en train d'armer
un certain nombre de responsables pour
protéger les colons en cjordanie c'est
une question qui a été évitée lors du
déplacement d'Emmanuel Macron et puis il
y a aussi deux approches différentes les
partenaires que auxquels on faisait
référence le Qatar la Turquie l'Arabie
Saoudite après tout pourquoi pas peuvent
être utiles pour la libération d'otage
pour la solution politique je crois
qu'on regarde pas forcément dans la
bonne direction car un pays comme la
Chine qui a lancé son initiative globale
pour la sécurité qui est le seul à avoir
permis un rapprochement entre le prince
héritier Mohamed Ben Salman et le Guide
Suprême ou le Président Ibrahim Raissi
et sout Iran Arabie Saoudite
effectivement poigné de main àin je
crois d'ailleurs que le président Joe
Biden avait cela en tête pour essayer de
ne pas se faire voler la possibilité que
le leadership de médiation ou de
facilitation ne soit plus occidental
mais qu'il soit oriental et
souvenez-vous qu'il s'était renvoyé la
balle quand même 2 jours après les
massacres et la Chine semblait pas
pressée de joouint un rôle dans cette
affaire mais peut-être que cette
déclaration n'étit pas en phase avec ce
qu'elle comptait faire en coulisse alors
il y a eu effectivement quasiment de
manière simultanée concomitante le
déplacement de Joe Biden en Israël et
puis il y a eu le sommet des routes de
la soie à Pékin au cours duquel pas très
réussi d'ailleurs 30 % de participant au
moins important ça ça c'est vrai mais
les amis de la Chine ont incité la Chine
à proposer une autre une alternative en
tout cas une autre façon de concevoir la
résolution du conflit il nous reste 3
minutes dans ce débat je voudrais quand
même qu'on qu'on parle de des
interlocuteurs potentiels d'une d'une
relance du processus de paix côté
palestinien parmi les les personnalité
que le président français a rencontré il
y a on l'a dit évidemment Mahmoud Abbas
le président de l'Autorité palestinienne
et écoutons-le c'était juste après ou
juste avant cette rencontre avec le
président
français en ces moment nous vous
exortons vous président Emmanuel Macron
et les pays membres du Conseil de
sécurité à faire cesser cette agression
contre notre peuple à Gaza à fournir une
protection internationale immédiate et a
convoqué une conférence internationale
pour la paix nous appelons à une
solution politique plutôt qu'à des
solutions militaires et
sécuritaires et la mise en œuvre d'une
solution à deux états
conformément au droit international est
ENF à l'occupation du territoire de la
Palestine avec Jérusalem Est pour
capitale le territoire de Gaza fait
partie du territoire palestinien occupé
depuis
1967 marmoun Abbas c'est le le leader
palestinien présentable mais est-il pour
autant
crédible on le sait l'autorité païienne
a été très affaiblie ces dernières
années et la crédibilité du leader on a
pris aussi un coup je pense que son
niveau enfin son Cotat de popularité
politique est aussi bas que celui de
Benjamin netanahou donc je pense aussi
que si le processus de paix reprend à un
moment sera ni avec l'un ni avec l'autre
je crois ensuite pour ce qui est de sa
crédibilité tant qu'il ne condamnera
pas l'attaque terroriste du 7 octobre
estce qu'il n' à ce jour toujours pas
fait publiquement c'est impossible d'en
faire un interlocuteur crédible et on le
sait qu'il a que l'Autorité
palestinienne continue de verser des
salaires aux familles des terroristes
c'est impossible dans ces conditionsl
d'en faire
de continuer à en faire un un
interoculur crédible c'était déjà pas le
cas avant mais après 7 octobre pour les
Israéliens en tout cas c'est impossible
et et je enfinà et c'est quand même
entre eux que les négociations se font
donc est ce qu'on peut imaginer un proc
on se projette
loin un processus de paix et des
négociations avec des Palestiniens qui
ont condamné le Hamas et l'action du
Hamas bah souvenez-v auourd'hui on
enensble très loin souvenez-vous que
Donald Trump avait proposé une
résolution du conflit sans les
Palestiniens le fameux plan du siècle ou
le donc qui avait été proposé par son
gendre Jared Kouchner euh je crois qu'il
y a quand même un élément qu'on oublie
par rapport à mammoud Abbas c'est qu'il
n'est plus crédible par les pour les
Palestiniens lui-même oui car il y a pas
eu de vote depuis 2006 oui donc en fait
on érige en représentant du fata
quelqu'un qui n'a pas été élu ou qui
pour lequel le processus politique ne
s'est n'a pas été rendu dire la même
chose du ramas il y a pas eu d'élection
non diff le Hamas avait fait un coup
d'État et justement le Hamas n'avait pas
reconnu la légitimité de mamoudabas
c'est la raison pour la qu il avait
rompu à partir de 2006 non c'est
particulièrement compliqué effectivement
de penser un processus de paix avec une
vie politique israélienne une vie
politique palestinienne qui est mouvante
et je crois évidemment et je pense qu'on
est d'accord sur ce plateau que si
négociation de paix il devait y avoir
s'il devait y avoir un nouveau plan de
pête tel qu'il a été proposé par
l'Arabie Saoudite en 2002 les
représentants palestiniens Israëliens ne
seraient pas ce qu'on a actuellement
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat Jérôme clèche je
rappelle le titre de votre livre
prospective stratégique publiée aux
éditions Herman à bientôt sur Public
Sénat